Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Cerbera Odollam also known as "The Suicide
Tree" contains a potent alkaloid toxin that
is nearly impossible to detect in autopsies
making it a common choice for murder when
masked by spices in food.
What the FAK!?
The facts and knowledge on Deadly Plants.
The neurotoxin delivered from the Gympie Stinger
of Australia is strong enough to kill certain
animals and humans.
When the broad leaves of the plant are touched
by human skin, small needle-like hairs penetrate
it causing a horribly painful sting.
Entomologist Marina Hurley describes the experience
as, "like being burnt with hot acid and electrocuted
at the same time."
Moroidin, a bicyclic octapeptide is the compound
believed to cause the excruciating pain and
symptoms can last months after contact, especially
in the cold.
There is no cure for the sting, and using
wax to pull the hairs from the skin is the
only recommendation for relief.
Conium maculatum commonly known as poison
hemlock is known for killing Socrates.
It's widely distributed throughout the world
and is considered an invasive species in 12
U.S. States.
Conine, the dangerous chemical found in Hemlock
has a structure similar to Nicotine that disrupts
the central nervous system and leads to respiratory
failure.
Ingesting any more than six to eight leaves
can be fatal without artificial ventilation
for the 48-72 hours it takes for the effects
to wear off.
Water Hemlock and is commonly mistaken for
parsnip which is a problem because it's North
America's most toxic plant.
Within 30-60 minutes of consumption people
experience nausea, vomiting and tremors - followed
by severe cramps, projectile vomiting, and
convulsions.
Any amount of the Water Hemlock will likely
cause death or permanent neurological damage.
Livestock is highly susceptible to the poisoning,
causing death to cattle within as little as
15 minutes.
The sap that covers the large broad leaves
of the Giant Hogweed plant is extremely dangerous
when combined with human skin and sunlight.
It grows all over the world and the sap contains
photosensitizing furanocoumarins, which cause
severe burns when exposed to sunlight.
The scars can take 6 years to heal and minute
amounts in the eye can cause permanent blindness.
It's so toxic that it's illegal to import
into the United States without permission
from the Department of Agriculture.
The Angel's Trumpet contains toxins that induce
hallucinations described as terrifying.
The tropane alkaloids cause paralysis of the
smooth muscles, confusion, auditory and visual
hallucinations, increased heart rate, and
even death.
Another effect is turning people into so-called
zombies, with alleged stories of unsuspecting
victims being drugged and then obeying the
commands of a criminal, allowing themselves
to be robbed of all their possessions.
Abraham Lincoln's mother was possibly killed
by White Snakeroot.
It's native to North America, contains the
poison Tremetol.
Drinking the milk or eating the meat of livestock
that have consumed it causes severe trembling,
vomiting, and intestinal pain.
Despite being rare today, during the early
19th century it was the cause of death for
thousands of European Americans.
The Castor Oil plant is used in medicine as
well as for lubricating car parts but the
seeds contain a highly poisonous toxin called
Ricin.
It inhibits protein synthesis and a dose the
size of a few grains of salt can kill an adult
human when inhaled or injected.
Symptoms include abdominal pain, severe diarrhea,
and circulatory shock.
Death occurs within 3-5 days but a full recovery
is expected as long as medical treatment is
administered.
I'm gonna leave you with this plant - what
is it and what is it rumored to kill?
Before we go here's last video's winner.
Leave your answers in the comments below but
sure to subscribe for more Vsauce2 and as
always - thanks for watching!